[Music]
enjoying amazing food in Chicago all
week you people have the best food in
the world and my favorite my favorite so
far
definitely the Chicago style hot dog
love that hot dog but possibly the
greatest invention in human history
now I wanted to celebrate it okay so
tonight with the help of Chicago's own
Vienna beef company we're gonna break
the world record for longest Chicago
style hot dogs
[Music]
[Applause]
tell us about this incredible Weiner
this hotdog is from the Vienna beef
company it's 40 feet long that's the
length of a t-rex the bun is 40 people
and also made by Chicago's alpha banking
company since in Chicago style it's
covered in three pounds of pickle spears
one pound of sport peppers 2 pounds of
relish 4 pounds of tomatoes 4 pounds of
onions 2 pounds of mustard and 1/8 of a
pound of celery salt with everything on
it this record-breaking hot dog weighs
37 pounds that's almost two one
hundredths of a ton yes
[Applause]
I give you the world's longest
chicago-style hot dog
we tried
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice save Andy now we tried to get
someone from the Guinness Book of World
Records to come and verify that this is
indeed the longest chicago-style hot dog
but they blew us off yeah
however we were able to find a guy
drinking a Guinness at a pub across the
street here he is at Denis he's going to
verify this for us
tell us what do you think that is one
big freaking dog
[Applause]
thanks guys take it away you're just
gonna leave in there all night thank you
we're just gonna leave it there all
night that's got to be against against
some kind of violation yeah in some
violation there will still eat it
afterwards